hey yeah what's poppin guys and with all
my friends cuz I love French you know
what can I say I am a lowly software
engineer oh yeah what about you Jeffrey
so as I said before I was gonna do a
giveaway and I decided to give you guys
air pods now to enter the competition
it's quite simple you're gonna have to
click a link on the description
basically what you have to do is you
have to I think I have to be subscribed
to the YouTube channel to get one entry
wait just a minute I'm vlogging and then
also if you like my page on Instagram
you also get an entry and then if you
follow me on Twitter you also get
another entry and I think there's a
questionnaire to ask you like what your
favorite video is and you also get an
entry like that so yeah so that's how
you're gonna that's how you can win an
air pod don't forget the LinkedIn video
is gonna come out soon so be on the
lookout for that it's gonna be pretty
interesting LinkedIn was my favorite
internships I have a lot to say about
that so I'm quite excited oh look my
friend is here he made it yeah good job
and also in case you're curious I will
be doing multiple giveaways as we go
along so I was thinking of doing
giveaway at a thousand subscribers which
is you know now and then two thousand
five hundred five thousand and then ten
thousand yeah I mean if I reach ten
thousand this year I'll be pretty stoked
also I just want to say thank you so
much guys I'm really happy reading all
these comments I read every one of them
and yeah I just really appreciate you
guys taking the time to watch my videos
I'm just really happy I mean I made this
channel cuz you know I wanted to make
tech more openness accessible and what I
mean by that is that you know a lot of
people don't know what it actually means
to be in tech or like in Silicon Valley
and I just want to show you guys that
you know we're pretty normal people you
know I'm just you know we're just pretty
we're pretty dumb you know you don't
need to be really smart to join us and I
just wanna you know make it a little bit
more entertaining so that's more
consumable for everyone because I I
really appreciate the Silicon Valley
culture or like the tech culture and
yeah I just want more people to know
more about that so
I know he's are you ready let's go
[Music]
No it's small but hurts like hell man
all right we have to go home dude yes
you patrol guys
[Music]
oh why do I even make ski boots then
thanks for watching guys now don't
forget to enter the competition you have
to follow me on Instagram and follow me
on Twitter and sir a few questions about
which is your favorite video and also
comment on this video below any
questions you have for me because I do
want to make a Q&A video and hopefully I
have enough questions if not then oh
well but yeah thanks for watching good
luck
[Music]